much of what passes for modern
journalism today consists of taking some
obvious feature of physical reality and
declaring that it's a myth uh this claim
is then supported with a series of
assertions along with frantic assurances
that there's at least one study out
there somewhere that supports whatever
they're asserting
we discussed an egregious example of
this last week with the scientific
americans documentary series seeking to
debunk
the concept of the sex binary
and this week the new york times has
gotten in on the action with this op-ed
titled
maternal instinct is a myth that men
created
now once again you see
um
the the thing that you always thought
existed
you've always known existed and you've
witnessed yourself and maybe experienced
yourself and which all of human society
has believed in and professed and bore
witness to
is a myth
not only that but it's a myth very
recently invented by patriarchal men
sometime around the dawn of the
industrial revolution
this is the claim that the writer
chelsea conneboy a journalist
specializing in health it says in her
bio wants you to believe
the article itself is lengthy and takes
many irrelevant detours into anecdotes
about women who suffer from postpartum
depression
she talks about a commercial that she
saw once at one point she cites a
stand-up special by a comedian named ali
wong like this is all evidence that she
marshals to prove her point there's a
lot of fat to trim from the bone but um
i think this portion here which i'll
read to you captures the essence of her
argument so this is what she writes
the notion that the selflessness and
tenderness babies require is uniquely
ingrained in the biology of women ready
to go at the flip of a switch is a
relatively modern and pernicious one it
was constructed over decades by men
selling an image of what a mother should
be diverting our attention from what she
actually is and calling it science it
keeps us from talking about what it
really means to become a parent and it
has emboldened policymakers in the
united states generation after
generation to refuse new parents and
especially mothers the support they need
today many proclaim that motherhood is
neither duty nor destiny that a woman is
not left unfulfilled or incomplete
without children but even as i write
these words i doubt them do we
collectively believe that maternal
instinct is still frequently invoked in
science writing parenting advice and
common conversation and whether we call
maternal instinct by its name or not its
influences everywhere belief in maternal
instinct and the deterministic value of
mother love has fueled pro-family
conservative politicians for decades
oh god forbid
those pro-family politicians you know
a uh a sinister bunt bunch and we get to
the substance of the argument there such
as it is um which i think can be handled
pretty quickly
first of all
whether maternal instinct exists or not
and it does we'll get that in a second
the idea certainly is not modern you can
read ancient writings from across the
world including the bible and text even
older than that and find beautiful
homages written to to uh to the special
bond between a mother and a child
like every
ancient civilization has noticed this
and remarked upon it
not just remarked upon it but
built their civilizations with that in
mind
if there's anything unique about our
view of the subject
it's the opposite of what the author
claims only in the modern industrialized
west will even think to question whether
a mother has a special bond with and
duty to her own child this is not even a
subject of discussion in other cultures
nor was it through history because the
answer was so obvious
maternal instinct was self-evident to
our ancestors
and like so many of their insights this
one has only been confirmed and
validated by modern science even if the
new york times would like to claim
otherwise
there was an article written in this
smithsonian magazine in 2021 titled the
new science of motherhood and it goes
into great detail about the biological
and neurological changes a woman goes
through when she becomes a mother
which serves to bond her even closer to
her child this stuff has been measured
you can see it
in fact the new york times itself the
new york times itself in 2008 published
an article with the headline maternal
instinct is wired into the brain
it reports the results of one of the
many dozens of other scientific studies
showing how a mother's brain is
miraculously
wired to connect with her own child
reading from the article says tokyo
researchers used functional magnetic
resonancing imaging mri to study the
brain patterns of 13 mothers each of
whom had an infant about 16 months old
first the scientists videotaped the
mother smiling at their rather
videotaped a baby smiling at their
mothers during playtime
then the women left the room and the
infants were videotaped crying and
reaching for their mothers to come back
all of the babies were dressed in the
same blue shirt for the video shoot mri
scans were taken as each mother watched
videos of the babies including her own
with the sound off when a woman saw
images of her own child smiling or upset
her brain patterns were markedly
different than when she watched the
other children there was a particularly
pronounced change in brain activity when
a mother was shown images of her child
in distress the scan suggests the
particular circuits in the brain are
activated when a mother distinguishes
the smiles and cries of her own baby
from those of other infants the fact
that a woman responds more strongly to a
child's crying than to smiling seems to
be biologically meaningful in terms of
adaptation to specific demands
associated with successful infant care
the study authors noted
but
the maternal instinct doesn't just kick
in when a woman actually has a baby and
lots of things do happen and a mother's
brain is wired a certain way
and uh there are hormonal changes and
all these things
but girls from a young age are much more
inclined on average long before they
have kids of their own
they're still much more inclined on
average to exhibit maternal traits
there's a reason why girls play with
baby dolls that's what playing with a
baby doll is all about
i mean think about you you've got little
girls who are
my daughter's two years old she's
already pretending to be a mother this
is what she loves to do more than
anything in the world it's to carry your
baby dolls around
now sure there are some boys who might
show an interest in baby dolls also but
they're the exception
nearly all parents on earth and who have
ever lived on earth
have noticed in their daughters an
inclination towards these sorts of
things
the left wants us to doubt what we've
all seen what we all know to be true
and all they can give us to justify the
doubt are anecdotes about exceptions to
the rule
and yet at the same time these very same
people validate what they claim are
unfair stereotypes by in the next breath
insisting that a boy who shows
maternalistic traits is probably
actually a girl
they can't get their own story straight
so i couldn't take them seriously even
if i wanted to and i don't
also we haven't taken into account the
animal kingdom where the females of any
given species are not only on average
the most likely to be primary or sole
caretakers of the young but also where
even among animals
mothers are often observed sacrificing
themselves to protect their young
how do we explain that
are chickens and polar bears and
elephants also subject to social
conditioning and political pressure
have they been manipulated by dastardly
conservative politicians
now of course human beings are different
from chickens and polar bears and
elephants in that we are self-aware and
we're capable of making moral choices
and this is the one possible criticism
of
maternal instinct as it relates to
humans that i would entertain
is that you might argue that calling a
human mother's love and devotion to her
child an instinct
diminishes it
you know when a mother rushes into a
burning building to rescue her child
it's not just instinct that is she's
making a choice she's making a heroic
choice
and we should acknowledge that she's not
merely obeying her biology like some
kind of machine
but all that means is that human mothers
have a maternal instinct along with
something far more powerful
which is a soul a mind
capable of making these kinds of choices
the writer of this article is aware of
that actually and that's really her
point
she wants women
to use their higher faculties
to reject their maternal instinct
override it
turn it against itself
and deny everything that makes them
special and unique
many women in our culture have done
exactly this tragically violently
rejecting their motherly vocation
through abortion
increasingly there are women who reject
womanhood entirely and have doctors cut
out their female reproductive organs so
they can live as some bizarre mutilated
approximation of a man
and this is what the writer ultimately
wants
and what the left wants generally
which is why
when they deny
that things are a certain way
what they really mean
is that they think that things ought not
be that way
this is one of the most important things
understand about the left
when they look at physical reality and
they say oh no it's not like that
no they know that it is like that what
they're saying is it shouldn't be
this is something we should destroy to
the best of our ability
they want us to live as if a certain
reality is not the reality
maternal instinct exists
but it shouldn't i mean that's chelsea
conneboy's real point
and it's why she is today finally
cancelled
i know you're craving some more matt
wall show content well i have some great
news for you if you head over to
dailywire.com and subscribe now you can
watch or listen to my full show you can
also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcast i'll see you there